okay we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 the next caller is from the 4-1 to
area code I think that that's Pittsburgh
correct me if I'm wrong
now that's correct but what's your name
where you calling from my name is David
[ __ ] means human super nacre
I'm calling from Pittsburgh area and no
dude yeah I know this guy calls the
Howard Stern Show
he wants to you're the guy who wants to
normalize the use of the n-word right I
want it to be Dee race aside I wanted to
means human I think that it and also
words like [ __ ] shouldn't be used ok
so I want I want to use it to try and
fix it ok and how's that going you've
been doing this for what like 10 years
now I've heard you I've heard this guy
call he's kind of well-known he's called
into like every show and he says he
wants to normalize the n-word is that is
that going well so far would you say
that's like going too bad I've got some
people that are on my side I got friends
that understand and then I I you know
it's going pretty well but what I really
like to have eventually would be in the
dictionary
yeah the full change so that means human
to everyone else and that's a really
difficult proposal unless you're a
publisher and you've got book deals or
whatever yes or to get a word to change
in the dictionary itself the questions I
have for you right now though was how
you felt about expanding the minimum
wage to people that are incarcerated and
also expanding the votes to them as well
how do you feel about that it would
probably take a constitutional amendment
yeah I mean I believe that if you have
served your time in prison and you leave
prison that you have in the eyes of the
law you've made good based on the crime
you were convicted of so I think you
should absolutely be allowed to vote and
I also believe that it should not be
allowed to pay you know these these
penny and our wages a big corporations
making money on the back of the
incarceration industry I'm against that
as well it's shocking that I found two
areas of seeming agreement with a guy
whose main
goal for the last 10 years has been to
try to increase the use of any word but
hey you know politics makes strange
bedfellows right well yeah and that's a
very sensible response it's why I Love
You Man I watch you all the time I don't
think it's too weird to be a proponent
of an word I think I found some
surprising support from people and oh
yeah I mean especially in the in the
times of Trump I'm sure there's no
shortage of people that are thrilled to
be using the n-word more ya know you're
talking about racist though it's like
all right people or something I'm sure
they use them word in their own
situations but none of them
self-identify as a [ __ ]
all of them have you how is the other
and they hate the other so much all
right Dave thank you so much
really appreciate the call that's bet I
mean that guy's kind of well-known I'm
sort of flattered that that someone
who's known for I mean yes something
completely pointless and of waste of
time
actually called into the show but that's
someone I'm very very much aware of and
have been for a while that's quite the
hobby I wonder how he got started in
doing something like that yeah yeah
there may be a question for another day